so we have negative 30 x to the fifth is
equal to negative 10 x to the third
times f and i encourage you to pause
this video and see if you can figure out
what f is going to be
well the way that we can tackle it we
can just isolate the f on the right hand
side here if we divide
by negative 10 x to the third
so we might say well we want to divide
this side by negative 10 x to the third
but if we want the equality to be true
if we want the left side to stay being
the same as the right side we have to do
we have to whatever we do the right side
we have to do the left side as well so
we have to divide the left side by
negative 10
x to the third and then what does this
what does that leave us with well on the
right hand side up top we're multiplying
by negative 10 x to the third and then
we're dividing by negative 10 x to the
third well multiplying by something and
dividing by the same thing is the same
thing as just multiplying by one or you
could one way to think about they just
cancel out so we are just going to be
left with an f
we're going to be left with an f on the
right hand side
there's a whole point we wanted to solve
for f and on the left hand side we see
we can first look at the coefficients we
could say
negative 30 divided by
negative 30 divided by negative 10
is positive three
so that's going to be three
and then x to the
x to the fifth power divided by x to the
third power well that's that's that's
going to be x squared
x
squared you can either think of it in
terms of our exponent properties we
would subtract these two exponents x to
the 5 minus 3 which is x squared or you
could say hey up on top that's x times x
times x times x times x did i say that
right 5 x's you could view it as x let
me do it in that
on top you have x to the fifth which is
this
i almost like to remind myself why the
exponent properties even work and then
on the denominator on the denominator
you have
x times x times x and these three x's
are going to cancel and you're just
going to be left with x times x which is
just x squared so you get f is equal to
3 x squared so you could write
we could write that negative 30
x to the fifth
is equal to
is equal to
negative
10
x to the third
times f and now we know that f is 3 x
squared
3
x squared and so another way to describe
what's going on in this equation we
could say that negative 30 x to the
fifth is divisible by either one of
these factors that negative 30 x to the
fifth is divisible by negative 10 x to
the third or we could say negative 30 x
to the fifth is divisible by 3x squared
or we could say that 3x squared is a
factor of negative 30x to the fifth and
the way that we can make these claims
about factor and divisibility is we're
dealing with we're dealing with
non-fractional coefficients right over
here and we're also dealing with
non-fractional exponents right over here
so that's why we're saying hey these are
factors this this yellow thing and this
magenta thing factors of this blue thing
or this flu blue thing is divisible by
either one of these